I helped make as Liam Neeson's [ __ ] I
don't know what's a lot that's the
question these are some of our favorites
from from this week Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big every horse ride turns into a
joust Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big you
can walk across it to get to Asgard wait
a mrs. [ __ ] is so big he was able to
join the mile-high club without flying
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's
ashamed of how small its human is Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that after sex
Liam Neeson goes limp Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big when he gets crabs he doesn't
use a lotion to get rid of them he uses
artillery Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
donkeys in Mexico pay to see him [ __ ] a
woman is a good really good Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big if placed
carefully it can almost hide Ralph's
eyebrows wait a minute what the [ __ ]
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when he was
in the womb it looked like his mom had a
huge dick - assuming it was hanging out
good Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big you
trying to comprehend it put Stephen
Hawking in the chair
[Applause]
good Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when
quit from jaws saw it he said I'll catch
this [ __ ] for you but it ain't gonna be
easy it's not like going down the pond
chasing blue girls and Tommy cards this
[ __ ] swallow your whole little shaken
little tenderizing and down you go and
we got to do it quick that'll bring your
bass battling back your tourists but all
your business is on a paying basis but
it's not gonna be pleasant
I value my neck a lot more than 3,000
bucks chief I'll find him for three I'll
catch him and I'll kill him for ten but
you've got to make up your minds if you
want to stay alive and ante up you want
to play a cheap or be on the welfare
roll winter I don't want no volunteers I
don't want no mates there's just too
many captains on this island $10
thousand dollars for me by myself for
that you get the head the shaft the
whole damn thing
[Music]